so I wrote last week about the emptiness
in our culture and in the hearts of many
people in our culture which I think is
at the root of our current suicide
epidemic it also it's at the root of of
pretty much all of our problems in our
country we have we have fled from God we
fled from meaning we've fled from
purpose and we've embraced this kind of
nihilism although we don't call it
nihilism nobody would actually call it
that anymore we use other words and
phrases to kind of soften it up a little
bit so we'll say things like you only
live once and live your truth and those
sorts of things but they all mean to
communicate a nihilistic perspective on
life people are told that there's only
one life only one reality it has no
meaning aside from what you assign to it
and then the question is well what
happens when you stop assigning meaning
to it what happens when you stop finding
meaning in it
well our culture says if you don't
assign it if you don't find it then it's
not there because there is no objective
meaning it's only what you find now
after writing that piece I was on the
plane home from home from Denver or I
was speaking at the Western conservative
summit which is a great event by the way
and I was reading a collection of
soldier isten writings
this book right here which is a great
book by the way I definitely picked this
up and I flipped to a speech
that he gave in 1993 this is after I
just so happened to write on this
subject and I was I was reading through
this book and I flipped through a speech
they wrote in 1993 I wanted to just pull
this up because it speaks exactly to
what we were what about what I was
writing about what we've been talking
about now it's not a coincidence that I
happened to find that theme written
about in a solider distant book because
this is a theme that he talked about
throughout his whole life that he kept
going back to but the the the speech
that he gave in 1993 who did he give
this speech - okay he gave this to the
International Academy of Philosophy and
a speech is called we have ceased to see
the purpose we have ceased to see the
purpose I want to read a little bit from
because I think it's really powerful he
says we have allowed our wants to grow
unchecked and are now at a loss where to
direct them and with the obliging
assistance of commercial enterprises
newer and yet newer wants are concocted
some wholly artificial and we chase
after them in mass but find no
fulfillment and we never shall the
endless accumulation of possessions that
will not bring fulfillment either modern
Transportation has flung the world wide
open to people in the West even without
it modern man can all but leap out
beyond the confines of his being through
the eyes of television he is present
throughout the whole planet all at the
same time yet it turns out that from
this spasmodic pace of techno soundtrack
progress from the oceans of superficial
information and cheap spectacles the
human soul does not grow but instead
grows more shallow and spiritual life is
only reduced our culture accordingly
grows poorer and dimmer no matter how it
tries to drown out its decline with the
din of empty novelties as creature
comforts continue to improve for the
average person so spiritual development
grows stagnant
Comfort brings with it a nagging sadness
of the heart as we sense that the
whirlpool of pleasures does not bring
satisfaction and that before long it may
suffocate us no all hope cannot be
pinned on science technology or economic
growth the victory of technological
civilization has also instilled in us a
spiritual insecurity it gets gifts
enriched but enslave us as well all is
interests we must not neglect our
interests all is a struggle for material
things but an inner voice tells us that
we have lost something pure elevated and
fragile
we have ceased to see the purpose let us
admit let us admit even if in a whisper
and only to ourselves in the hustle of
life at breakneck speed what are we
living for so I guess I should just end
it right there because soldier distance
art is spoken so I can't really I can't
really add to that and say anything more
profound than what he already said but
this is really the problem the problem
is is is well it's twofold I think first
we don't know ourselves okay we don't
know who we are
and second we don't know our purpose and
I think a person has to know both of
those things or he will be in despair
and if we have a culture a country a
nation a civilization of people who are
confused on both of those points then
you will have a civilization of despair
and I think that we're living in a
civilization of despair
because we have a crisis of identity and
a crisis of meaning
I don't mean to keep throwing books at
you but as I was thinking about this I
wanted to do a video on it and then I
remembered another book Kierkegaard the
sickness unto death which is a very
difficult one to it's not exactly a you
know cover to cover Beach read type of
book it's it's pretty heavy stuff but um
the sickness unto death and carry
already talked about he explains in the
introduction that from the Christian
perspective from the Christian
understanding even a sickness that kills
you does not really lead to death it is
not a sickness unto death because death
is only the sort of gateway into eternal
life but if we reject this and if we see
ourselves as only temporal then that is
the sickness that leads to death to
despair to destruction on the first page
of the first chapters book jerker guard
says a human being is a synthesis of the
infinite and the finite of the temporal
and the eternal of freedom and necessity
and he goes on I won't read more than
that but he goes on to say that
basically argue that a man is in despair
when he denies or rejects or gives up on
one aspect of that synthesis so when
when when we give up on the eternal and
infinite and truly free aspects of our
being and we don't see ourselves as
spirit anymore you know we don't see we
don't recognize that
that part of the synthesis of our being
then that's when we fall into despair
because a man like that doesn't know
himself and thus doesn't know his
purpose
and so he's in despair know yourself and
know your purpose that's the point here
I think as a culture we tend to fail on
both counts
so I want to let's just look at this one
at a time
so first
know yourself know your identity it's no
coincidence that the discussion of you
know things like gender identity have
have gripped ahold of the nation at the
same time that the suicide rate clams
through the roof it's no coincidence
that trans quote-unquote transgender
people have such an astronomically high
rate of suicide I believe that for
transgender people attempt suicide at a
rate of about forty percent
now the rate for the rate for the entire
nation is climbing but the general rate
for everybody is like four or five
percent which is still high forty
percent
is just a shocking figure why
why would you have 40% of people in a
particular demographic cook attempt
suicide
it's not enough to say well you know I
know I know the claim that what leftist
will say is well it's because they're
bullied now that I'm sorry that doesn't
explain it there have been many groups
of people who have fared much much much
worse in society than modern-day quote
transgenders do and yet they never
attempted suicide anywhere near that
rate I mean think about black people up
until civil rights think about black
people during slavery they certainly had
it worse in terms of their liberties and
their treatment in society than
quote-unquote transgender people do yet
actually what you find usually among
persecuted groups in any country
throughout history is you find actually
the reverse effect you find that the
suicide rate will actually go down most
of the time in face in the face of real
harsh persecution because there's this
kind of resilience that is sparked
but that's with transgenders 40%
why well because I think Kierkegaard was
on to something there's a profound
despair that comes with not knowing who
you are with not knowing your identity
without Reckitt without when you don't
recognize the synthesis there's a
despair that comes and it seems like a
lot of us are very confused on this
point a lot of us don't know who we are
even if we don't identify as a sex
opposite from our physical one it seems
like a lot of us still struggle with
we don't know who we are and from there
you get everything from gender identity
to plastic surgery and and beyond
I mean think even of the people who are
I mean this manifests itself in so many
ways think about the people who are
obsessed with fashion trends and they
have they have no identity of their own
they they have no sense of themselves
they just wear what everybody else wears
they say what everyone else says they
develop the same interests as everybody
else they kind of fade into the
collective and and the trends and the
fashions everything it's more like
camouflage for them because it's meant
to blend them into their surroundings or
think of all the people who call
themselves super fans of sports teams or
superheroes or sci-fi franchises or what
have you
I'm not talking about regular fans I
mean I mean people who are utterly
obsessed with some form of entertainment
it's just it's their whole life it's the
primary thing they care about and if you
say anything critical of it around them
they will lose their minds
they
there was a there was a national review
writer a year or two ago who wrote a
critical column about Star Wars and she
got death threats for for insulting Star
Wars now think about the kind of people
that would send death threats because
you don't like the fantasy make-believe
movie that they like these are people
who have no identity so they have just
found one in this make-believe story
think of you know to think of the
proliferation of communities like
everything is a community these days
what whether it's your sexual fetish
then if there's there's there's a
there's a community for every sexual
fetish there's a community for every
obsession for every enthusiasm for every
interest for every hobby no matter what
it is you're part of a community of
people who share that with you people
look for their identity and their shared
love for things and experiences and
entertainments and then there's probably
the worst symptom of our identity crisis
as a culture maybe not the worst but
still pretty bad one those who identify
themselves primarily and mostly mainly
first and foremost as Republican or
Democrat now that there's anything
necessarily wrong with having a party
affiliation although I mean increasingly
I do think there's something wrong with
it actually but I'm not really talking
about that I'm talking about people who
have tailored their whole identity
everything they think and believe
according to what the party says or to
what a politician says there's a very
common phenomenon these days on both
sides of the spectrum of people who you
know they'll say one thing one day
they'll say the next thing I'd totally
opposite thing the next they're their
principles change by the minute it seems
according to what their party says to
what their politicians say to what
they're talking heads say they've lost
all identity they are now nothing but a
letter R or D they have no capacity to
think or a reason beyond that
you
now this is all wrong I think
I think if
any chance at being a well-rounded happy
person
I need to have a clear understanding of
myself of Who I am
I need to have an identity that's rooted
in something solid and unchanging
so I have to know first that I'm a human
being and that I'm a man this is the
most basic physical form of identity
that's my most basic physical identity
and I've got to know that that's the
starting point if I can't even get past
that then there's just that there's no
hope of me forming any kind of identity
whatsoever so I've got to know that and
then I have to know my identity it's
sort of a deeper kind of level I have to
know that I'm a child of God and then
I'm a husband I'm a father all of these
things this is really my idea that's my
true identity it's that's really Who I
am so if you were to ask me who are you
what's your identity
that's what I should say before I say
anything else that and that's kind of
the the trunk and those are the roots of
my identity that's the roots in the
trunk and then from there
all the little branches and twigs and
leaves and everything those are all the
kind of superficial things that are also
part of who I am but they don't matter
that much so I'm a Ravens fan I like to
read books written by dead Russian guys
okay I make a mean pot of chili but I
like five guys it's the best fast-food
restaurant that's not gonna be debated
by the way I'll do a separate video on
that some other time so those are all
things right those are all those are all
in a sense part of who I am but they
don't matter that much and you those are
the branches the lit the leaves the twig
you could come and chop those off those
could fall off they could they could
change you know they and it doesn't
matter it won't change who I am I'll
continue along being the same sort of
person
because my identity is rooted in
something more solid more real more
eternal than just my interests in my
affiliations and my proclivities I think
a lot of people today
are they don't have roots and they don't
have a trunk they're just a bunch of
branches and twigs and leaves
I think there are a lot of leaves being
blown around detached and weightless and
helpless because they have no identity
a person who identifies themselves first
and foremost
by some interest of theirs or some
proclivity that's just a leaf that
person is nothing they've reduced
themselves to just a leaf laying on the
ground
and they can easily be blown away
second thing so we need to know who we
are and then we need to know our purpose
you know we need purpose
some idea as to why we are here
even if I Know Who I am now I need to
know why I am
and we're on going
and this deep desire for purpose and for
meaning that's what separates us from
animals your cat doesn't consider these
questions your cat never sits around
thinking what what am i why am I
where's all this headed the cat doesn't
think that cat doesn't think anything
you just can't just wants to eat use the
litter box whatever knock your drinks
over that's all your cat wants to do
doesn't think about anything else that's
what separates us from in it's also what
separates us from machines I know
atheists will talk about people as if
we're just a bunch of biological
machines they'll talk about us as if we
are computers covered in skin basically
but even the most advanced computer in
the world doesn't desire meaning even
the most advanced computer in the world
could never want to be anything more
than a computer they can't conceive of
anything else computer has no desires
whatsoever and can never develop them I
know science fiction we like to think
about what what if a computer ever
becomes self-aware it will never happen
it's impossible it cannot happen
now we we want to be something more than
flesh and bone
and I think even some of this struggle
with some of the struggles with identity
people wanting to change their gender
and so forth some of that I think is
rooted in a real
true and healthy desire that we all have
to be more than what we physically are
it's just that they have missed or they
have wildly misdirected those desires
but there is a fundamental desire there
CS Lewis points to this as proof of God
he points out that nature would never on
its own create in itself a desire for
something beyond itself if we are
nothing but the result of natural
processes we never would have developed
the ability to think about those
processes or analyze them or be
skeptical of them or question them or
pine for something beyond them
you
CS Lewis says that your the fact that I
that I desire something beyond this
world means that I was made for
something beyond this world
if there really is no God in the
universe I never would have found out
that there is no God because I wouldn't
have the consciousness to know that
there is no God so there's clearly some
other component to the human person
there there's something else in us
something immaterial something that
can't be grasped something that can't be
seen and thus could never be transferred
or programmed into a computer and that
thing is consciousness self-awareness
the capacity to make moral choices the
ability to recognize and appreciate
beauty the ability to love
our souls in other words that's the
thing that's the that's the the extra
component that we have we have eternal
souls and it's our souls that crave for
truth and meaning and purpose beyond
just this physical life our culture may
tell us well live in the moment you got
to just live in a moment enjoy the
moment
but nobody lives at the moment nobody
just enjoys the moment nobody can
in fact the only people who really live
in the moment are the people who are in
absolute despair
and are on the edge of suicide
a person right before committing suicide
that is a person living in the moment
that's what living in the moment
looks like it looks like dying
because that's what it is
so really live in a moment is to despair
of anything else but this moment
you
but those of us were not at that point
we know
that there's more to life than that we
have always this sensation of movement
know that we're rushing towards
something Ford's tomorrow
you know there's always another night
always another morning just around the
corner then a year and then ten years
and we know that we're just barreling
we're barreling at breakneck speed
towards something towards death and then
something
so yeah we should enjoy the journey but
our enjoyment of the journey really
hinges quite significantly on what we
are journeying towards doesn't
I remember when when our twins were born
and there were our first kids and they
were born premature and there were
health complications and they had some
breathing trouble so they had to
immediately be whisked away up to the
the NICU and I remember when the nurses
came down to get me and bring me up to
the NICU to meet our children and I
remember everything about that moment I
remember walking through the hallway
I remember the hallway I remember the
elevator
I remember the sights and sounds and
smells I remember everything I remember
even how it what it felt like the
temperature in the building
and
I'm there was joy mixed with a lot of
fear and anxiety and everything else but
looking back on it now it's all joy to
me now I remember it as as joy even that
walk down the hallway
I remember that walk down the hallway as
moment of joy
there was a kind of very short journey
to my new life as a parent
my point is that the journey was joyful
was joy
because the end was joined because I was
going towards something joyful I was
heading towards a new life but what if
I'd been walking down a hospital hallway
you
what if instead of walking down a
hospital hallway to greet my newborn
children what if I was walking down that
hallway to say goodbye to a dying child
could you tell me to enjoy that journey
tell me to live in that moment
no I don't want to live my moment I'd
rather die in that moment
but you can't say that because I know
where the journey ends in that case I
know where it's leading and it's leading
to despair and death and just emotional
ruin so there's no way to enjoy that
journey
there's no way to live in that moment
without dying in it
the point is that our ability to enjoy
the moment and to enjoy the journey
depends very much on the end
on the destination if we believe
or we've told ourselves that the
destination is eternal nothingness if we
believe that we're hurtling towards
obliteration and the cessation of our
being
then what joy can there really be in
life
how could you possibly enjoy life
especially a life that unavoidably is
going to involve so much suffering and
sadness
and suddenly in that case it all becomes
a cruel joke our consciousness our
ability to understand the joke is itself
the worst joke of all nature in that
case has put all the creatures on the
earth on a path to decay and and final
death
and the obliteration of their beings and
their essence
but then it gave human beings the
knowledge of this fact
if that's the case then we got the raw
deal didn't we
we should look with envy on beasts and
bugs
because at least they can just live
their lives and not think about it
but this idea that nature created
consciousness in a human being just so
that we could spend our lives dwelling
on the nothingness and pointlessness of
the very existence that it granted us I
mean that is that view of life is just
it's it's it is pure unadulterated black
despair that's what that is that's what
that view of life is
and if you look at life that way you
know you look at bugs and dogs and cats
and you might think I'd like to be one
of them but you can never be them
but it's very hard for us to live with
with
with the knowledge of the futility of
our existence and the pointlessness of
it and so then we begin to think that
maybe the second best alternative is
just to get it over with already
that's the result of a life lived
without a sense of purpose or
destination
but
if we embrace our true purpose
to believe in that destination
and the God who created us for it
um
if we know our meaning and our purpose
and our identity
and our substance
then we've opened ourselves up
so for joy
and hope
that's the only way
that's the only way to live as a person
it's also the only way to function as a
society and as a culture
is with that sense of meaning and
purpose
and the great thing is that
to have this sense of identity and
purpose it not only is the best path to
joy it's also the only path to truth
it's also true
it's even I would say self-evidently
true that there is more to life than
just there's more to me than just this
the very fact that I can contemplate
this and wonder about it
for something more is proof that there
is more
because nature would not create a desire
which is doomed to just be eternally
frustrated
that doesn't make any sense that that's
not in keeping with the Darwinian theory
of things
so it's best we become more functional
and more joyful when we have identity
and purpose and it's also true that we
have identity and purpose so that's
that's I think the really good news here
that is the good news right in the
entire universe that's the good news is
that there's more there's more than this
alright thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed